et vous avez vu tir j'ai été coupé en
pleine émission oui alors ce que voulait
voir ce qui s'est passé en fait on va
mourir en fait comment ça s'est passé
sur le plateau quand on a appris qu'on
était plus diffusés voilà parce qu'en
fait on savait pas du tout moi je
continue à jeter dans l'émission j'étais
bien j'étais bien dans ma tête j'étais
parti pour un marathon télévisé abymes
je me prendrai que la bible dans la
jugulaire partie ils ont appelé tout le
monde la production ils ont appelé dylan
nizan pet ou même mais l'info c'était
des pmp avec lelynx.fr ni comment réagir
quand tu veux nous qui peut couper le
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est fini merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
les gens foutres et on va très bien
l'art c'est d'ailleurs un million 4 1
bravo l as roma bravo à tous les joueurs
de liverpool chez qui nous regardent on
va mettre ça l'alhambra les chéris donc
voilà on a été coupée et vous inquiétez
pas rien à voir avec ça pas empêcher les
gens de faire de ce rock twitter des
trucs genre on a été coupée parce qu'on
allait faire des révélations fait les
gens sont fous comme c'était juste une
émission circoncise voilà merci